John wick chapter two I'm thinking he's
back again except this time his dog's
alive thank God
stop doing that to me movies I like dog
me I don't want to get too much into the
plot of John wick too because the
trailer actually mercifully doesn't
really let us know what the movies about
you just know that John wick is back and
someone is in his sights and it's not
you know a good stare that he's given
them he's angry he's mad just me and
he's gonna kill them and that's John
wick Chapter two
there's something else going on of
course but I just want you to discover
it the way I discovered it because I
went in not really knowing the
undercurrent of this movie and I'm
pleased because it was really fun to
uncover as the film progressed because
this is yet again another extremely
badass movie from the opening scene of
this movie where we see an old Buster
Keaton movie in black and white being
projected on the side of a building and
then were immediately transported into
this action scene that tells us that we
are about to see a stunt lovers heaven
Buster Keaton if you know anything about
the history of film is one of the best
stunt men ever he pioneered a lot of
stunt work in movies and he's known as
one of the best of all time and so right
from the beginning this movie the
filmmakers are letting us know that
that's what they're going to be focusing
on here and my god it is an action movie
lovers wet dream in every possible way
if you appreciate amazing action scenes
if you like good stunt work if you like
when they're well filmed and well
choreographed when you can see
everything happening and you can look
the main actor in the eyes and know that
he's actually doing 95% of it himself
then you are going to love this movie
and I had a total blast of it from start
to finish one of the things that I loved
about the first John wick was the
organization that you learn exists in
this world that John wick was once a
part of and it seemed like this really
awesome world that was just waiting to
bloom and waiting to blossom and a lot
of people commented on that and you can
tell the filmmakers heard that when you
watch this film because it really
beautifully explores the ins and outs of
what is essentially a modern-day mob
John with two is very much so a
modern-day mobster move
we don't have people sitting in suits
behind a desk going oh yeah I'm gonna
give you enough so you can shoot in the
first film you saw the Continental the
hotel where business was not to be
conducted everything was very sacred
there and in this movie you get to see
that as well as a lot of background
politics with the way all of it works
and it's actually kind of fascinating
this movie has a longer runtime in the
first one and a lot of that is dedicated
to exploring this underground world more
I was liking it too the raid too when
compared to the raid but the first one
was just a straight-up action movie the
raid 2 was like hey let's have a lot of
action but also explore this underground
world of this criminal organization a
little more John wick - does that while
also having a lot more action than even
the raid - did and again I can't heap
enough praise on the way these action
scenes are filmed Keanu Reeves is just a
fuckin badass the stunts that he does in
this film and the entire stunt team the
way it's all assembled it's beautiful
it's gorgeous
to watch even though it's very violent
it's extremely well choreographed and
very well filmed the finale action set
piece reminded me quite a bit of Enter
the Dragon the Bruce Lee film there were
a lot of callbacks to action films that
are famous if you are someone who's well
versed in action movies this film is
also not just a mobster movie it's sort
of a modern-day Western as well there's
quite a bit of standoffs
there's even a guitar riff that goes
through the score quite a bit that
reminded me of music that's commonly in
westerns where the film faltered for me
a little bit is towards the end when you
begin to see more of this organization
and you begin to see how many people are
really involved with it I think it
pushed the boundaries of realism to the
point where it got a little cartoony and
it was a little hard to believe a friend
of mine who was with me felt the same
way up until then I didn't really have
any major issues with it safe for one
which I'll get into in a second but
there's a sequence towards the end of
the movie where I just kind of went no
no no I don't buy it
sorry you lost me you lost me there and
that's never a good thing to be reminded
that you're watching a movie when you're
kind of locked in to the grit of it all
and then be like oh that was a really
big move
a moment that I just don't buy all that
being said John wick is essentially a
guy who has a 100% aim perfect headshot
cheat code installed into his brain so I
can't really take it that seriously and
the motivation in the first John wick
was so clear and so streamlined it was a
very emotional motivation for why he
goes back into action in this film he's
kind of forced and he just sort of has
to he doesn't really have much of a
choice
and what makes characters and movies
interesting is the choices they make and
when your character is just kind of like
hey you you got to do this you just have
to the emotional reason for him being
there wasn't as impactful as it was in
the first film all that being said what
they accomplished with the stunt team in
this movie and what Keanu Reeves has
done with consistently putting forth an
absurd amount of effort into his films
and if you don't believe me look up his
combat training video from the first
John worketh on YouTube it'll blow your
fucking mind this guy is so dedicated
and what they've all done is to be
praised for one specific reason nobody's
hanging from a helicopter nobody's
jumping off of rooftops onto another
rooftop
nobody's you know flying through the air
at Mach speeds this is all in camera
insane amazing stunt work on the ground
hand-to-hand combat gongfu all of this
stuff is is things that you can do on a
very low budget and the fact that it's
so mind-blowing what they can accomplish
without doing any of these major
superhero we type stuff that's to be
phrased I'm going to give John wick
chapter 2 of B+ I really had a blast
with this movie I feel like it's a more
focused story than the first film but
the one thing that kept me from liking
it just as much as the first if not a
little better was his emotional reason
for being there this time around it was
more of a hey you just have to do this
and deal with it which is kind of cool
but also towards the end it does kind of
push the limits of believability beyond
that this is a total blast I can't wait
to see it again hope you guys check it
out this weekend as always thank you
very much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuff my nice
[Applause]
[Music]